Comic book fans the world over are starting
to realize that Black Panther just might've
changed superhero movies forever.
From its jaw-dropping aesthetic choices to
its cast of butt-kicking women, Ryan Coogler's
Black Panther oozes style — and substance
— and the cinematic landscape is better
for it.
Think back to Phase One of the MCU.
Remember the great jokes, the impressive costume
design, the heartfelt expressions of heroism.
Now try to remember every female character
from those movies as you can.
Spoiler alert: They're mostly the girlfriends.
You've got Pepper Potts, Peggy Carter, and
Jane Foster... plus some side characters like
the irrepressible Darcy, Sif, Frigga, and,
ultimately, the introduction of Black Widow.
It's not the most dire situation in Hollywood,
but generally speaking, if you're not there
to smooch, you're either set dressing or the
one very special lady Avenger who still spends
a chunk of every movie trying to seduce her
prey.
Even Phase Two's introduction of Gamora in
Guardians of the Galaxy fell into the same
pattern, as she's relentlessly pursued by
Peter Quill throughout the film.
"NO!"
"What the hell?!"
"I know who you are, Peter Quill!
And I am not some starry-eyed waif here to
succumb to your… your…
PELVIC SORCERY!"
Then came Black Panther in Phase Three and
its cast full of women.
There's Nakia, Shuri, Okoye and the Dora Milaje,
Queen Ramonda, and women filling out the royal
cabinet.
Women were everywhere in Black Panther, doing
everything.
Both within the MCU and outside of it, this
was pretty revolutionary.
While Captain Marvel's starring role in 2019
was in development for years, Black Panther's
amazing cast of women may have gotten audiences
ready to receive the film a year earlier.
Blockbuster movies don't typically bet on
the unfamiliar — which makes Black Panther
feel like kind of a miracle.
It has a majority black cast, takes place
in a fictional African nation inspired by
real African cultures, and features actors
speaking Xhosa, an official language of Zimbabwe
and South Africa.
It is deeply rooted in specific places, histories,
and aesthetics that most of the worldwide
audience knows little about.
And it made over $1 billion worldwide.
Black Panther didn't just prove that people
all over the world can embrace lives outside
their own spheres of experience — it proved
that they can fall in love with them, cheer
them on, and come back for more.
Superhero movies tend to look the same.
Save for a signature color or a formalwear
scene, it's all based in ultramodern tech
and military drab.
This can be an interesting look, of course,
but it does tend to blend together into a
canvas of olive green, stainless steel, and
dark suits.
Thor shook this up admirably, and, with the
release of the positively psychedelic Thor:
Ragnarok, cemented its branch of the MCU as
a risk-taker.
For a while, you had three choices: you could
be surrounded by SHIELD black or army base
grey, or you could be in Asgard.
The thing about all of these aesthetics, even
Thor's, is that they're familiar.
We know how action movies look, how high fantasy
looks, how military movies look.
The MCU did them all well, but they'd been
done before.
Then in strides Black Panther, with its wealth
of color, texture, and fashion both ancient
and contemporary.
Audiences saw the deep green of the River
Tribe, the bright coral of the Dora Milaje,
and Shuri's up-to-the-minute bomber jackets.
Costume designer Ruth E. Carter, who won an
Oscar for her work on Black Panther, managed
to bring color, history, and an entirely unique
Afrofuturistic aesthetic the majority of the
audience was unfamiliar with.
It's not just cohesive, it's not just new
to the genre, it's not just rooted in an absolute
avalanche of research — it's all of those
things and more, packed into one movie.
Marvel's home base has always been New York
City.
This has done a lot to bring a unique sense
of place to the stories that take place within
it: Daredevil, She-Hulk, and Spider-Man all
live in locations you can visit, that their
creators grew up in, that mirror the rapid
changes of 20th and 21st-century life with
a specificity that's hard to replicate in
Metropolis or Gotham.
Peter Parker is a boy from Queens, just as
Daredevil is a child of Hell's Kitchen.
The city, to use a well-worn but very true
cliche, is as much a Marvel character as Captain
America.
But that can start to feel a bit confining,
especially when the same city is splashed
across the screen over and over again.
Marvel branched out, for sure — Guardians
of the Galaxy went far afield indeed — but
there wasn't anywhere with the same strength
of location until Wakanda came along.
Rooted in painstaking research of actual African
cities and cultures, Wakanda looks, sounds,
and feels like a real place with real history.
"Sister Nakia.
My Prince.
We are home."
Audiences agreed, cheering when the heroes
returned to Wakanda in Infinity War.
Black Panther didn't just show that audiences
can invest in MCU locations beyond NYC and
outer space — they can feel right at home
there too.
"Wakanda forever!"
T'challa isn't the first royal in the MCU.
Thor, of course, begins his journey as heir
to the throne of Asgard, on a path to discovering
what makes someone worthy of that authority.
Loki has been twisted by his desire for kingly
power into a perennial villain.
Both men — as one might expect — find
themselves often engaging in battle.
This isn't a flaw — these are, after all,
action movies.
But T'Challa's kingship is defined as much
by his role in international diplomacy as
his ability to send forces into battle.
Much of Black Panther is concerned with how
best to share Wakanda's resources with the
rest of the world, how to aid in global conflicts
responsibly, and, tellingly, how violence
has typically led to tragic outcomes in Wakandan
history.
We don't see T'Challa commanding conquering
armies — rather, we see him consulting his
advisers, speaking at the United Nations,
and engaging in ceremonial combat as a means
of transferring power.
"Wakanda will no longer watch from the shadows.
We cannot.
We must not."
T'Challa is a diplomat first and a warrior
second, a man who leads his troops into battle
reluctantly.
Superheroes, post-Black Panther, aren't confined
to the Pentagon, military bases, or other
martial visions of world power — they debate
others, open community centers, and strive
for global cooperation.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.